And in the time they turned to find the
tweezers to tug of the ticket from the tip
of their dick.
They had children
and children's children they grew
a coat of many colors about them
that waxed in the old wave of
their waning aquarian waters
that washed and fed divvied child
that poured the life in the day
of a day in the life of an inn
in my village in ratted
hair and proud rags.
There are dead stop travellers
wrapped in concrete.
Find silver rings pierced there
is no use and lips and nipples.
There are people sleeping under
my home under my pillow under my
dreams under my children under
my money under my pipes under my
wiring and arrests and dogs
down in the old arsenic
and head to claude dusts they
sleep under my sleep on the
carpet of my winter's
hearth. Around the bend.
I hold my baby on my one street town.
I walk past my paper man past
my glossy magazine fantasies my
princess liz and my princess di
and my princess caroline pass.
A glossy tears and gowns.
I walk past my real estate persons.
People are sleeping under my real
estate persons sleepwalking sleep
dealing sleep talking
outside my rainbow cafe.
They are raining inside my
rainbow sad drizzling rain
or tables of glass eyes rolling and
their smoking up a storm raving
and rainbows
and arrows people are sleeping
under my footsteps lying to
my face.
They are dying into my eyes my
street is their bedroom argument.
My foot path a back door bathroom fix a
kitchen sink quarrel for the into my
eyes an argument about
bags and debts and loans
and threats about money
and where were you.
And where's my money and you ripped
me off when i was ripping you off
when you ripped me off the
rip rip rap the riffraff rap
the ragtag tit for tat. I
am wall to their window.
Do you are no higher bag of boredom
microphone to their mouths.
Just water for glass eyes to sale
nor spoonfed ink to their
barbs to use to tolerate a
once enchanted drug.
Down the track to being stoned just
to be nearly normal to be nearly
normal
and then.
Labels. Of babel.
There's hippies and yuppies and
greenies and junkies and drinking.
Smokers and tokers and
dope the sbt and jokers
and mope as ball kickers and ball hitters
and ball tares with pit bull terriers.
Drummers and dancers and dipsticks and
dubos yobbos into rose and musa as
and prayer goes an embryo journos and
two rows and musa. And i start again.
I missed a line. To court up and
pointing at you. Labels of babel.
There's hippies and yuppies
and greenies and junkies
and drinking his smokers and
tokers and dope feeds and jokers
and mope as ball kickers and ball hitters
and ball tear as with pit bull
terriers drummers and dancers
and dipsticks and dubos yobbos
and two rows and musa preggers
and embryos journos and
photos and letters are those
and homos sapiens
and hetero sapiens are not
so sapiens stoned builders
and mud brick is an organic effluent
powered plumbers and joiners metal men
and amazons and the
goddess in the kitchen.
There's painters and poets and
potters and butchers and bakers
and candlestick makers cobblers
and weavers and woodturners
and tailors mad hatters and
mask makers and face painters
and glass bead game shakers.
There's yogis and barbers and babies and
swamis and shaman and she men and sufis
and surfers and skaters and. Like as.
Ferals and herbals and healers
and dealers and wankers
and yankee and japanese
and jerry's and frenchies
and pom is a mad irish
to be sure to be shot
or to be shiite to be shiva to be
shipwrecked to be washed out watered down
unemployed uninspired to
be you. To be a teenager.
To be secondary primary infant
pre-school daycare aftercare care less.
Care free without a care to be
unheard unknown just to be seen
and smelt
and passed on the street a pedestrian
a shopper a robber a dobber a copper
a cream a loiterer a waiter a talker a
laser tongued a lizard an outpatient
a schizo a dip so as on be a
runaway to be a coffee stop to be
frosts. And farmers and
grazes and gardeners
and loggers porticoes in a grows to
be a shooter to be shot cyberpunks
and funky s and goblins and gothics
and rastas and rats daytrippers
and night trippers and trapped in their
trips tripped out trippy trekkers
and turned on tantric tale tellers
divine lighters and cloud liners
and takeaway diners. To be lovers.
To be left overs to be left
right up down as to be around
and around as we can work shoppers
and co-dependent conference hoppers.
Mid-life crises for midwives with
vices and shotgun divorces over him
and horses to be labels to be labels.
To be glue sniffers of a stick on
labels in the cafes of the streets
of babel on the road from
babel to babylon to bourke
and back.
Easter parade.
They drive on up from the city of yup
they come on down to the radical town.
The one street town of the hippie
and the clown year old hairy man
and young barefoot woman
with suckling babes. Mrs.
No bras and mr battered cars
to see a life that's free.
Free love free drugs free music
free footpath free gatta
free falling over free
flight and free fights
and what's not free just to see.
They walk the town all city
fled for a bit of a dare.
But then they're scared their culture
shocked their culture locked
and in the mind of travel their ships
dry docked for their clothes away
in their shoes so bright this skin is white
their teeth their white their car is
nice and their kids like mice with
heavy metal megadeth sweatshirt hype.
They window shop but they smell the pot.
They sniff the calf. But they don't stop.
No cash or coins bulge their fashion lines
for their credit card is raise a fine.
It cuts a slice they can call
mine simply divine and it's mine.
They ask where are the real hippies
in their maya we say standing on one
sire is that chap really
chained to a dog and his mate.
Look the queen of the bog triffids
doesn't. Zombies prodigals.
Parasites psycho movie
extras that great washed.
Or dead. But cammy easter
bunnies on a crucifixion dawn
when nailing chocolate coated junkies
onto crosses so forlorn not with nails
but syringes and not for a soft heart
freak show cringes but for the crowd
and the cameras and the
mums and dads and kids.
Tunnel vision unscrews from their third
eye it guides them safe back to their car
by by.
We dust their footprints from our
face climb down from the cross
and clean up the place.
Barry hoses shopkeepers sweep and scavengers
the lick nuggets from the street.
The streets of nimbin aligned with mud
over gold lined with a purple green
we need that's worth as gold with peace.
And guns and plenty and poverty and law
and anarchy come and say
or better still piss off.
It was written in october
1986 nimbin razor mirror.
It was a town where we used to love
each other in the streets in the
park in the rain but to hug
and hold and massaged.
Some say no it wasn't it was never
that even before the smack attack
the sharp edge was there axe blade
wedge saw plough brush cutter
knife a century of timber
cut. Yet as
and came carter's lismore was a two day
hike before they wipe the red cedar from
their path wildmen few women two wars.
A depression isolation a recession of
one industry decaying into the next
the hills strewn with the bones of trees
and beef in dairy till
the town was near goes.
And the valley was ripe for the hippy.
Then came the word and the word was a
goth smiling down check and benefits
and grants a festival
that still life born again mushroomed
pregnant on astroturf the deliberately
poor became multiple occupants booming
babies building broken families building the
house the trees rebuilding the car rewinding
relationships through a hassle of hope
and rip off. The dropkicks of
drew and. And strange dropouts.
Feeding friendship through a slot machine
the sweetness turns savory savvy
one streetwise in the mirror of the
knife the mirror of the needle words
and eyes can still cut the rusted blade
rests cold on the cheek of the valley
and we who used to love.
We are the spit and whetstone honing
that blade losing each other into
the raised history of the valley.
Only we can sheath the anger
and the knife.
I keep going.
Rainbow rabbit.
Mary go around the forest dusty hippies
while dreaming caravans watching
compost walls and the logging trucks
roll past flapping plastic wind.
Beast turns turtle.
Turns based turns bored in a
heartbeat changing channels changing
tires in a mud to grumble
seed planting a jungle board.
Beginning that rainbow rabbit.
Merry go round the forest dusty
hippies while dreaming caravans
watching compost walls
and the logging trucks roll
past flapping plastic wind as.
Beast turns turtle turns beast.
Turns bored in a heartbeat changing
channels changing tires in a
mad grumble seed planting a jungle
bog nit picking snake skin ticks
below fly below and
helicopters sniffing drugs.
Paradise bird startle waving at a
sunset showers the last rainbow
fades the mountain and
twilight crashes the valley.
Fresh dripping terraces of flowers
and greens marie is in tune.
The car breaks down the town
wakes up friday driving drink
and drugs forest wetbacks
rural debutantes dogface
and the hippy farmer smith then black
and brown storekeepers barefoot natives
and the black cracking lepers of
gypsy junkies changing bandages
and bend down as changing small change
into broken veins all rubbing together in
the front bar and seeing and hit the
drum. I fix the car and get out.
Back into the meanwhile our
gumboots of fried rice boiled rice
veggies and rice buckets of lentils
buckets of rain roaring down the roof.
Mould creeping across
the kitchen wall mould
and white answer of the old guitar
and the slush of red roads breaking hearts
and cars fever in cabin families
trapped in strawberry fields for ever.
Way down the wet gully of palms and guns.
And river below and i
wish to know of miss.
Hurrying through sleep into heat delays
in days backwards into town blowing
that creek diving valley into facing
visitors again and the garden.
Somewhere between in the
mirror of deep green mountains
and the children rabbits round us all in
bounds of the spring heat waving into
summers and gone.
The art of just been lucky
i've just been man of just
the.
Nimbin is kiss and smack.
Many many pregnant pauses death and birth.
And birth. And birth and birth and birth.
And birth and death and rebirth and be on.
Nimbin.
Where rents out patients
and healers the freedom just
to be anything or nothing.
And every morning they
hope is the town clean.
Nimbin is
that hallucinogenic smell of the forest
days the while the moon dance is
still cloning and the wood smoke
and the pub breath misting thick
above the grand piano nimbin
is what turns suburban
refugees into saints
or scumbags de facto husband and wife.
Rumors of a hot showers.
A thousand new plan to trees.
Around a garden of rusting rotting.
Nimbin is far it and not.
Out the sparrow i have breast
milk curdles yellow on fresh dole
cheques.
Nimbin is what's passed the
brood of astrologers in new.
Nimbin is initiated ground always.
Take what you need give what you can
and go the selling
of nimbin natural. If you please.
We sell it as cheese as carob
or cow a dry banana a weekend retreat
will massage your feet with scented oils
or then tana if your kundalini
falls will mud brick your walls
and cloud your hopes with
dopes we so by the touch.
We sell by the smell by the
pinch or pound powder.
Need us down drive will talk you into the
grave but we charge more to come back
and be saved. Rebirth. Why not
reincarnation where we've got $10 billion.
Book or a thousand for the lot.
Doubt your actuality will
change your sexuality
and will rent you a flower by the hour.
Want to be bored pay ask to be ignored.
Two weeks in the park will turn your
day into down a swim at the pool
or drown of the pub
or a movie down at the record with
dinner for two black snag a rice do you
and can deliver talk of the sec
to me you can marry some german
and they'll pay you for certain.
It's better than life in a nine curtain or
you're after some land or just a share.
We sell by the inch at prices so rare.
We sell it as dresses and printing
presses and pottery and plates
and solar panels and paintings and poets
and postcards and performers and punks
and potted palmistry and
pure herbal therapy.
Take a droog home for tea take some
children for free or just a small fee.
It's all for sale. You see even me.
Plus designer nudists skateboard
meditation and alternative the lounge
or a we sell pawpaw at the
plumber's condoms at the garage
and prescriptions at the drapery there's a
sky channel at the hotel with helicopter
police as well we're all getting
straight or we do the fiddle
and if you want class. Well where or all
in the middle. You may think i'm joking.
Well must run my dear the shops
to be open the tour bus is here.